I am the control I am the I I have I
understood this I've never said it out
loud oh okay but this is a life hack
dude okay go ahead are you ready for a
life
[Music]
hack
Runk hello
hello
hello hello
will
hello
hey look dude you're wearing a hat hell
yeah yeah I got a hat well it's that
company dick who um Donnie the dick you
know him hell yeah dude I I know his
Instagram really well he uh sends me
stuff and this is a hat from his company
and you know I'm just supporting that
hat looks good on you you look like as
you get older you look better in hats
you look like you I think I look okay in
trucker hats I don't look okay in any
kind of other hat maybe like a a ski hat
but that's it I don't look good hat a
beanie yeah like a beanie right right
right okay or no a full ski mask I look
fine in a full scheme mask best really
cuz then you don't get to see my face
cuz I'm ugly oh no
dude um yeah so anyway uh look check
this out dude it's January 7th probably
no definitely is Sun it is Sunday
January 7th without question all right
you want to get to patreon go to patreon
Lifeline luxury pon.com Lifeline luxury
we going make this even better for you
this year we're going to make the the
lifeline luxury has been awesome
actually and we're going to be it's
going to be really popping this year
though uh so go on over and sign up
Sacramento I'm coming Brea California
I'll be there Phoenix Arizona El Paso
Albuquerque Kona Vancouver BC added
another show sold out so just uh you
know go to Chris lea.com and get tickets
I'll be there coming uh to see you in
the city and I'm even going to Corpus
Christie Texas I've never been damn yeah
um and uh uh you know if you got a a
question or advice you want to you know
send us a video click the link down
below um my solo podcast uh the private
record is coming out this month baby
baby Bing b bing
bing so everybody be very excited about
that if you want to be on that show as a
guest you want to come tell us a story
go to the privat
record.com and submit yourself as a
guest all right you want one-one advice
sessions with me the Bing Bong boy go to
mata.com and book a session just like
that and of course if you want the great
merch the lifeline merch go to lifeline
merch.com and my special is out grow or
die so go to Chris le.com and watch that
dude it's a new year let's get it
started um yeah if you haven't seen that
you're just you're a bonee head you fix
that what a bone head you watch it you
become a non-bone head so uh it is the
New Year it's 20 it's
2024 and that's crazy right right it you
know what I remember I remember when it
was 2000 no I remember
when I remember when it changed I
remember the year it changed to 1990 and
I was like whoa a new decade cuz that
was my first new decade I don't remember
that but I was so young you were yeah
you were seven I was you were six or
seven seven right you were seven I was
10 no I guess I was six if it was going
into 1990 right and you were nine was I
yeah oh yeah you're right 1989 he right
right and so um and I remember that I
remember it was with Mike Le we were
with the Leos and we were like whoa it's
going to be 1990 wow the Leos dude Mike
Leo was his friend his age my friend was
Steve Leo he was my age atalian yep I
just started following Mike on Instagram
I don't know I don't know if he accepted
my thing sad they had an older sister
named Lauren and I always because of
them I always wished when I was a kid I
had we had an older sister really yeah
dude I always wanted an older sister
because of Laura in the Veo I guarantee
you she doesn't even remember me cuz it
was like I was so much she definitely
remembers you yeah maybe okay there's no
question right hey you were really
memorable to her yeah I remember um no
but I remember being at their house
being like damn there's like a girl in
this house that like lives here really
that would be so weird yeah I mean
that's Steve had to sleep over the same
night Lauren had friends over and I was
like this is right this is lit well this
is the Riz
based no
don't try to connect to the Tik Tock
saying dude what up ticktockers it's
it's rized it's not rized it's not R
Amed dude no it's not R I'm R Amed
that's an actor yep he's a great actor
he was in the the the one with that John
Toro was in oh the night before the
night after whatever it is I've never
seen that yet night after the night of
the night of wow I'm doing the sequel
and then the third installation is it
good it's really good it's actually
really good I kind see it man I always
want to see what that that and the
leftovers are the things I'm always like
I got to see that one and those are
things both of which that I like okay
all right how about that that's good
what are we doing in 2024 how we feeling
what do you do you do res a do you do
resolutions and B if you do what are
they this year I don't do resolutions I
don't either but I have one for this
year okay so you do them now well no I
mean I historically I don't do them all
right so I have one this year all right
and it it's kind of one and a half okay
so the main thing is that I want to
start treating
myself with as much respect and love as
I treat my friends and loved ones such a
white woman thing to say I just I think
everybody can relate to this though so
hard on ourselves and it like it results
in like a shitty mood and like a an ill
reflection of myself yeah and there's no
reason to I'm I care so much and I have
so much respect and like like empathy
and sympathy for people I love and my
friends and like why wouldn't I extend
that to myself yeah you know what I'm
saying mine's to talk more [__] about
you that's great that's actually so
weird I was just saying the other day
this is so weird it might have even been
yesterday that to someone that I feel
like we were talking about siblings and
I was like I feel like I'm probably
right to say that my my brother is the
maybe one of the only people that knows
me that probably never talks [__] about
me no ever that's so crazy never but all
but all but what what is talking [__]
though like I might say something
critical about you but I would also say
it to you there's nothing critical to
say about me which is what's crazy what
do you mean what's talking [__] that's a
good question uh like Jordan Peterson
like well on on one hand you'll have to
say what is [__] like like what is
talking you know here I'm communica him
how he does this or whatever no I've
never done that right I've never done
that ever in my life um and the other
thing the point if I have Lord struck me
dead
what if that happened it was on camera
people would never not believe in God if
they saw that like if you happened to
die right after you said that but I'll
tell you right now people will never not
believe in God well of course but I'm
saying everyone would see the video and
think it's actually pretty compelling
evidence I but even still nobody would
ever stop believing in God no one would
ever stop and I believe in Horus Christ
what are you saying you're saying nobody
will ever stop believe you mean you mean
will never be a time there will never be
a time when people doesn't believe in
God people don't believe in God of
course not yep there will always be that
belief I believe in Horus that is very
obviously true so I don't know why
you're saying it like it's some because
as time progresses science will become
more obvious obvious and you know but
belief in God if anything it only will
just shift it only shifts but yeah
people never not Christians Muslims Jews
we're not going not going Muslim Muslim
Muslim like musini Muslim no oh okay
well never mind then um the other one
though okay the point five is
to tell the people that I love that I
love them more oh cool oh so you have a
two two you have two that's why I saying
1.5 it's like kind of I get it I have
zero you have zero resolutions that's
just keep to keep going dude that's a
well that is a resolution but it's not
though I I could not do it cuz I'm going
to still keep going I'm not going to do
a resolution but you would keep going
even if it was right but I have my but
my back hurts same place as it always
does I stopped kind of yeah I stopped
working out for 10
days got sick um traveled a little bit
couldn't work out because I was in
Phoenix and it was raining like hell I
was going to work cuz I was going to
work out outside and then also it was
like pouring so I was going to go to the
gym and stuff anyway dude I was sick uh
and it it's really I was I was pretty
sick for two day for one day I was
pretty sick second day I was kind of
sick then dude I I I was just sick for
like 12 Days a little bit you know what
I'm saying I do know exactly what you're
saying sickness hangs on when I was
young it never did as I get older it
I've been I was sick in October dude and
like pretty bad pretty sick and I got
better in like maybe a week or 10 days
but there's like I still still have some
symptoms from that sickness you and I'll
probably have them until the next time
I'm sick and you don't think that
they're in your head what do you mean
they're I mean there can't be in my head
because of but wait and
and you're going to have them in till
your neck sick that's my sense it's not
going away for months you know what I'm
hoping is the next time I get sick then
it all is like we're done now hey you
know what dude you look good with that
kind of facial hair I think so too thank
you okay you figured it out at 40 you
figured it out I think I figured it out
I think do it like that the trick is to
when I'm
shaving don't go to the skin like I mean
obviously the mustache days but like try
to leave a little bit it everywhere else
but sometimes you can't and you mess up
you go a little too close in one spot no
what do you mean no cuz you can just I'm
telling you that I do that step it don't
do that what's step it step it have a
step on the thing put the thing on oh I
have those I've never used them oh wow
dude I only used nothing I you ever been
somewhere no never been anywhere hold on
all right so this is boring right this
is very very boring we're being very
boring often way more boring than this
yeah really sometimes okay great okay
great it's episode 91
wow that's crazy actually that we've
been doing this for four years yep um 91
episode 91 go on over to get patreon.com
Lifeline luxury get Lifeline luxury it's
on and popping over there it's honestly
so good okay I listen I don't listen to
every episode of this or watch every
episode of this but I do watch every I
just recently actually caught up on
Lifeline luxury really it's the best I
never watch anything I don't watch
anybody's podcast period Well I feel
like I have to watch this one one
because Mr [__] yeah he does a good
job Mr [__] wizman over here well he
doesn't [__] up okay Mr Mr otherman oh
he [__] up [__] up left and right so
you got to keep an eye on him just make
sure everything goes right so yeah I
mean he [__] up so much he's not even
here right now so and if and if Chris
was here and Anthony wasn't I would say
Chris never [__] up and Anthony's the
one that we would blame whoever's not
here yeah all right so uh all right good
so let's go into a um submission here
yep and uh can't wake up today Chris
Matt Jesus guys I I just want to thank
you so much
for you know I've never has no idea what
you're going really you know when I get
stuck in my own head and my own thing is
he far or not yeah i' I thought about
like putting said nothing so far videos
out there there we go okay of uh like
put [__] Jesus are you kidding I
thought about sending you guys a video
right and the amount of times that I've
recorded my problems and like heard them
out loud myself has just made me realize
how not that big of a deal oh that's
good it is and how sometimes so simple a
solution so just right in your [__]
face so thank you so much guys and we
didn't even do it literally it took him
so long to say that he said nothing for
95% of that could have said the thing so
quickly but he was so happy and pleasant
he he was great I'll tell you this I'll
tell you this much he said nothing
period he said nothing period Well even
the whole video what he ended up saying
wasting which is just thank you but what
he said from what I gleaned from that is
he's saying just making the video and
not even having to send it in making the
video forcing myself to say it
succinctly out loud made me realize the
solution to the problem that Rings very
true to me because very often like
especially with work I'll be like really
upset about something but personal [__]
too I'll write a long email or text and
then by the end of writing it I will
feel
better and I won't even have to send the
thing yeah oh definitely you know what
I'm saying oh yeah defin my advice in
even though it's SC an ask for advice my
advice is for situations like that is
always to like people are like I don't
know if I should write them and let them
know how much they pissed me off or how
hurt or whatever just write out the
email and save it so many letters to me
no I've never WR on you uh uh save it
and sit on it for like a day and I
guarantee what is that from alino and
something I don't know I think that's
from your bit about alucino from like
when you started oh you're right dude
didn't we talk about this Anthony yeah
yeah yeah yeah good input man excluded
me excluded me well no because he
laughed and I wanted to make sure and I
knew you thought that and I was anyway I
was doing detective work kind of Co
Mentalist um but yeah just sit on sit on
it and you'll be good yeah you probably
forget about the whole thing forget
about what if you write it out sit on it
yeah you probably forget about the whole
thing so I my therapist has uh suggested
doing that a few times and whenever I do
it I
start [__] absolutely balling really
oh yeah immediately I go like
this immediate okay okay okay yeah I've
done it maybe two three times and just
start immediately balling wow all good
once I Did It On A Plane the guy next to
me probably thought it was a nut joke
just so good I didn't even mean to dude
yeah well you didn't mean to cry no not
at all to cry that's what crying is you
surprise yourself you get overwhelmed
with emotion not me I'm always like here
it comes T minus one minute oh well
robot cbot T minus sadbot t minus one
minute what my eyes eyes rain in T minus
one Minot eyes rain you know poetry no
but that's how it would be in the
[__] robot movies I couldn't I hated
that why are why are my eyes raining and
it's like you know wow dude you know by
sentennial man yeah but you know know
crying if you know all the other words
you know your eyes aren't raining what
you're doing though is you made up a
thing that isn't in existence and got
mad about it yes I did do that okay cool
but it's probably real okay it probably
did happen I can imagine some student
film is like why are my eyes raining oh
well
definitely definitely a film and I'm
pissed Tak a shot me taking a shot at me
and you did it oh wait you went to NYU
too it is but I dropped out yeah cuz I'm
Gangsta honestly I should have dropped
out too I'm Gangsta honestly frankly I
should have dropped out to
you know what I'm upset about 2023 what
I declared it the year of the Bing Bong
early on I didn't really didn't really
like no it was the year of the bing bong
and that's so wants me to stop doing
Bing Bong you know um so
I [__] cannot wake up today dude and
also my back hurts and then also I'm
driving along here and I go like this to
look at something [__] pinched a
nerve dude damn that happens to you a
lot I wonder why you you're so like I
know you keep your body in such dud good
sh why is that happen to you so much so
this is what I'm saying I didn't work
out for 10 days that's why my back
[__] hurts oh wait what do you mean
why remember cuz I said I was sick and I
didn't work out my back hurts because I
didn't work out and then this happened
probably because I just got back into
working out I need to keep moving dude
my body is a machine it's like an
airplane dude you're a shark the
airplanes that crash are the new
airplanes you got to [__] have a well
oiled airplane that uses that works all
the time that is constantly in motion
I'm a [__] 747 I'm a moo you know
what a what a makeo shark oh a makeo
shark yeah if I don't keep moving I die
all right do you understand crash and
burn baby yeah I understand but but I'm
serious I have to keep moving okay and
that's for real dude I can't believe how
much worse I felt because I wasn't
moving
around interesting is it it is
interesting yeah I don't move around
nearly as much as you and and you know
how much better you'd feel if you did no
I don't and I'm not trying to push it on
you but I'm answering you you ask me a
question let me answer no I don't
because I don't do it I don't know how
much better I would feel because
no if you started doing it and I'm not
I'm not saying you should get it but if
you started doing it in 3 months your
life would be unreal and not to saying
it's not unreal it's unreal but it would
be so much more unreal that you'd be
like this is a fantasy your hair looks
good it's like a nine out of 10 today I
don't even
ask do you think maybe you don't know
when your hair looks the best I think
people think that hair looks good A
different I saw a thing on the
congratulations thing someone left a
comment it was an .2 I thought it had to
be you know what I mean it's like I like
when people rate my hair I I think that
my hair is sometimes banging and people
don't think it is and sometimes it's not
banging people think it's banging so you
have a different opinion than what other
people think sometimes about your own
hair sometimes but I have a different
opinion on what different people think
about anything because sometimes you
think a chair is nice sometimes somebody
thinks a chair is ugly yeah that's the
way it is I guess isn't it right okay uh
let's do another one
okay hey Matt and Chris just chat gbt
girlfriend checking back in with you
guys in a shocking turn of events we
have broken up since then and this is a
particularly brutal one for me so any
words of advice or encouragement about
breakups will always be appreciated from
you too on another note my brother is a
huge fan of you guys he is the reason
that I started watching congratul
and later oneline the reason that I knew
that I was oneline was because he heard
it and then called me to let me know
very cute um so shout out to Travis we
love him and uh I'm going through a
really hard time right now but you know
life rips anyway so thank you guys
because of it what what what I have no
memory what did she do her she broke up
with her boyfriend but did she say no no
I know I I remember what happened 3
seconds ago you were saying though you
said oh yeah I remember you oh she had
her boyfriend wrote her a love letter
she's like all I want is something like
significant and emotional from you like
write me something ni gpt1 yeah I
remember it
now uh well yeah that that that is but
you were going to break up with this guy
anyway my advice is to think change the
lens through which you're looking at it
obviously you're in pain but let it
allow it to soften the pain knowing that
I promise you that relationship was
going to end
regardless whether it's now or in 3
months 6 months so and and truthfully
and I can say this without actually
lying in any way to it's better to have
gotten it over with than have to deal
with it in the future yeah I know
definitely but and you may be in a lot
of pain you're obviously young and
you're sweet and you're cute you're
going to meet somebody that doesn't
write you love letters using chat GPT
and doesn't that sound nice I think it
does and I think that you should look
forward to that instead of looking back
and thinking about how look obviously
breakups suck dude even I hate when
people break up dude even when you want
to break up with the person and you do
it it sucks for you talking so pointedly
okay why what do you mean and even when
you break up and you I didn't think I
was doing that well you were to be
perfectly Frank okay well that's fine uh
people look at things in different ways
no but I think that you know uh
obviously I think you know this you're
going to be okay but
it's better to have gotten it over with
and it sucks for anyone in any situation
whether you get broken up with or you
did the breaking up doesn't matter it
sucks go ahead all you keep saying the
same thing you know that's why I said it
real fast but you cut me off so I wanted
to you said it real fast cuz I started
doing that no I said it real fast cuz
you were already exhibiting impatience
and it was pissing
me foreign
robot he was exhibiting impatience and
it was pissing me um so I forgot what I
was gonna say because you said the same
thing about oh and you could be you're
in a lot of pain but you could at least
you don't have neck and back pain like
me so you're making it by yourself cool
and that's fine but my hair is doing
really well
today don't touch it don't touch it no
that that's a fallacy dude what if you
think your hair looks
good don't not touch
it whoa what is this yeah dude here's a
here's a life hack dude but wait is this
a fallacy that's been shown to be true
or you think this I am the control I am
the I I have I understood this I've
never said it out loud oh okay but this
is a [__] life hack dude okay go
ahead are you ready for a life hack yeah
so saying your hair looks good mhm you
go like this someone says your hair
looks good and then I walk down the
street another person say your hair
looks good you go I better not [__] it
up yeah right of course
yeah get out of here that is not the
truth the second you decide to not touch
your hair it sits it settles it sits it
sits it gets stale if your hair looks
good it looks good because of the body
because of the activation of your hair
you have to keep it
alive so you have so you say my hair
looks good guess what I do so go ahead
say my hair looks good your hair looks
good thanks so much man well it's going
to still look good it does look good see
it's about the body it's about the
activation
dude Chris S
soon
Vidalia you know I was going to say
Vidalia yeah and that one's better yeah
it might be yeah Vidal is a funni word
for I was going back and forth for like
20 seconds you could have just said
Vidal S I know but I didn't want to so
that was not even on the table frankly
hey let me tell you something it is
so [__] obvious we're brothers that
it might we might be the most brothers
ever you know what I'm
saying yeah but explain more every
single [__] way dude I mean that
isn't true every single way we're
different though the way we look you
mean like out facing the way we sound
the way we are the way we bant B Sig a
mate even if we didn't sound or look the
way we look you'd still be able to tell
we were brothers we
Brothers wow the benter guy what what
was he speed dating sick and that was he
like speed honestly who [__] cares
never got [__] ever that guy dude yeah
you mean never had sex yeah well got
[__] got
[__] like sick in it
dude I'm going to bus I'm going to bus
sick that
dude sit on dildo
um I mean dude Jim Carrey damn
dude okay all it's all good another do
another one
yeah best hair hair 1998 Aman best hair
in
1998 play it what up CHR Matt have a
question about International
relationships for you um I've been in
Tokyo for a couple years now and I've
been seeing a Japanese girl now there a
couple problems she doesn't speak any
English I speak broken Japanese so we
can still communicate but definitely a
wall and I have American citizenship so
I'll have to return to America
eventually do you think that there's a
limit to these types of relationship
ship do you think it's a waste of time
would love to know if you have any
experience or had any friends that made
it successful um yeah love any insight
I've been a baby since day one but I got
to say this is my favorite podcast
awesome of all so please keep it up love
you guys make my week better every time
this raises something that I that was
cool yeah that is cool this raises
something that I've thought
about
um and I I don't know if I've ever said
it out loud either there's a bunch of
Secrets being exposed this podcast okay
I don't know if the secrets well I
something I didn't say out loud about
the hair thing I don't think I've ever
said this out loud either
okay not this but I'm going to say this
first uh I've
never dated someone that wasn't
fully English speaking you know have you
like seen someone for a few weeks Pro
probably I don't know I
mean the thing about that is that if
it's if there's one of them you would
remember if there's zero of them you
might say probably but if they no I mean
like I've been with women that are
foreign obviously but like have I've
seen him twice three times probably
right okay yeah but like I don't think
I've
ever I I feel like there is a barrier
well of course there is no no no but but
the language barrier no I understand but
I I I think I put it on more than that I
think that I I think that I I probably
am like to harsh on it cuz I think that
I would have a subconscious thing that
wouldn't be open to that because I would
think how am I going to communicate with
this person period when well you so you
know in any relationship that you're in
you like need there to be a specific
understanding of yeah humor yeah exactly
so like a lot of people aren't really
like that and anyway even Americans for
sure yeah and I think if you got over
the hump of the initial difficulty of
getting to know
someone without like speaking one
another langu like actual languages I
think it might actually be somehow
beneficial because think about it I mean
this is just totally theoretical I've
never I've only like seen people for
very brief periods of time like we're
talking like a month or two that are
like that don't that don't speak English
as their first
language it it's I agree it's very very
difficult um but obviously people are
different I think that the wow I totally
forgot what I was going to say that's
okay I starting to say I wasn't
listening I have stuff you know oh you
weren't listening cool thanks man um oh
no this is what I going to say I think
that once you get over that initial you
know what you're going to say you're wow
man you know trying to make me forget
what I was going to say so bad you you
might end up in a place that it's
somewhat in a way beneficial because you
can
chalk things up to miscommunication
that's the main deal yes that's the
thing your initial Instinct was to be
like well I doubt she meant it this way
it's probably just the language barer
dude you getting so much help from that
I thought you said have sex with your
sister I thought you said steal your
money and drain your bank account you
could save your feelings so often you
could be like oh that doesn't hurt my
feeling she probably meant something
else even if she meant like [__] you you
smell you could be like um she probably
she doesn't know what smell means like
she didn't mean to say that word she
meant you know what I mean like you
could chalk it up to any like any of
that [__] you could say is just a
miscommunication so maybe it's
beneficial in a in in a way that is
unexpected that being said I don't think
think it's necessarily A like you can't
just break up with someone if the
relationship's fine certainly if it's
working and both you are happy you can't
just end it because long term it seems
like inevitably it would be a difficult
thing to have two people you know what I
mean like if it's good it's good if it's
not it's not and maybe it's not because
of the language thing but if it's not
the language thing is fine yeah but then
you ask any woman what the number one
thing about you know being in a
relationship would is important people
like so many of them would say
communication you know yeah and they
would be right honestly for
long oops so disrespectful dude he's
like you know what ready for another one
um Anthony just thought we were done
leave that leave that in don't take that
got his heartbroken by a Japanese girl
and like was crying refus tears refuses
to think about it for one more second
and is looking at and is looking at
something that she gave him you know
yeah um so did you see the thing where
by the way how come it's considered
racist for you know if I were to
like [__] like people would be that's so
that's racist you're doing an Asian
accent you know people would say that
people would say that but yeah yeah I
guess they would whatever it's not but
we don't we also don't have to even talk
about it because what I'm going trying
to do is bring up this thing did you see
the thing did I send it to you you know
how like if if I say speak Russian or or
whatever you like what do a Russian guy
s you
go or whatever the [__] you know oh you
did send me I know what you're going to
say yeah bro I never thought about what
it's like
for like you can do that with with
English middle what he's going to say is
that he sent me a middle eastern man and
an saying like this is how American
English people but but the point
is I never thought about when they say
do a guy like speak speak
Cantonese like I didn't ever think about
what that might sound like to a somebody
in China sure you know what I'm saying
English in the reverse I see what you're
saying yeah yeah yeah yeah what does
that sound like for us in English well
that guy did really well we should send
it so you could play it yeah it was so
funny dude it was in it was in uh on
Instagram man yeah I sent it to you on
yeah there it is here I'm going to send
it to you actually I'll just do it
here s near hter
ocot they work launcher faing hter in a
people 3500 B wow bro that's so weird
that is weird I never thought about that
yeah and I'm a smart guy that thinks
about a lot of things well why would you
think about that though if you think
about because I've done the other way
I've
gone you mean to tell me you've never
thought I wonder how Americans sound to
people in other countries no that's not
what I haven't thought of what I haven't
thought of
is other foreigners could do what they
thought an English person sounds like
but if someone said like this guy can do
that you wouldn't you would think oh I
haven't thought of that you wouldn't
think oh that doesn't sound possible
right okay yeah right you're just saying
it hasn't crossed your mind what has
crossed my mind yeah well that makes
sense and that guy's really good at
sounding American it's crazy in a 45
rocket launcher what I found weird about
that was that my brain couldn't help but
tried to make out words for me bro my
brain was [__] listening to the first
time I didn't even understand what the
guy was doing I thought he was speaking
yeah I know yeah it's yeah is that weird
yeah yeah yeah yeah it is weird that's
how good he is yeah he sounds just like
an americ he sounds like a radio host
mhm you well which is what obviously
he's right taking it from not to take
any credit from him anyway let's do
another one you know we'll get into the
one that Anthony was trying to [__]
let's see okay finally Anthony you can
play
it fell asleep hey Matt hey Chris I'm
wondering what's the right way to
respond to someone who's extremely
aggressive and rude and threatening to
you this doesn't tend to happen to me at
all so I never really know what to do
but recently it happened a couple times
one time in particular I took my dog out
to poop and then I didn't clean up the
poop in the bushes and then this guy
yelled from his door at me and he said
clean up your dog's [__] I stepped in it
last night and so I apologized to him
and immediately went to clean it up and
then he said I'll [__] make you eat
it next time okay so I cleaned up the
poop and then I didn't really know what
to do after that and I was confused so I
just went over to his door a few minutes
later asked him what was wrong explained
the situation he was super after that
nice and then we resed it and I started
cleaning the poop more regularly anyways
after that cuz that was my mistake but I
kept replaying the situation later down
the line and wondering if I should have
been aggressive back or even not
accommodated him because he was being
such an [__] about it and I'm
wondering if there are times when
someone's such an [__] that it
actually demands being an [__] in
return or should one always be nice I
tend to be a pacifist and just friendly
with everybody even if someone's being a
total [__] but I wonder have you guys
ever encountered a situation like that
and felt it's not even right to be nice
back because this person's such a dick
that is so dick that he said that after
the thing but also you never know what
people are going through you know like
what if that guy's [__] family just
died you don't know and you would feel
deep empathy for that and you'd be like
oh that's why he's doing that and I feel
bad for that guy it's interesting that
you called in for advice when it is
clear that the way you handled that the
right way 100% to a te the perfect way
to do it because he ended up apologizing
to you what here's the thing your
experience with that guy is proof that
there I would say there were very rare
exceptions to this but it's proof that
it's never in your best interest to meet
aggression hyperaggression in this case
with hyperaggression because it'll never
go any place good but I obvious if
you're asking is it ever warranted or
even understandable to meet
hyperaggression with hyperaggression of
course because hyperaggression we get
defensive we feel attacked and we want
to either you know get super defensive
and go on the attack or like you know
run people don't typically do the ladder
also not just
necessarily the answer is absolutely yes
you you should when it it doesn't always
have to do with you like if there's a
lady near you that's going through
something that somebody's doing
hyperaggression or your kids abely right
so the answer is of course there are
exceptions to the rule of like you
should never meet hyperaggression with
hyperaggression but your experience is
literally the perfect examp and as we
say proof is in the pudding oh yeah
exactly as we all say all the time the
proof is is inside the puddings the
proof is literally inside the puddings
yeah okay um and also that
is what the that's so [__] to be like
after the guy was like oh I'm so sorry
like yeah I'll make you eat at this time
cuz you know it's not going to turn into
a thing cuz you know you got a nice guy
it's like he wouldn't have done it if
you were yeah yeah dude I hate that yeah
yeah yeah yeah what the [__] does the
proof is in the pudding oh dude
something happened you're just going to
whiz by that huh no it made me think of
it oh oh
okay I was an [__] to someone mhm
recently and I'm a lot better at dealing
with things now that I've done a the
that I'm in therapy and like I I think
about things more but so I was
I my
car [__] I did this thing
where I was driving somewhere I think it
was to the gym I'm really buff and then
I get I did the and as I was driving to
the gym I was like oh I got to get gas
on the way home right I'm not going to
do it on the way to the gym because I
want to get to the gym got to the
gym did the gym got in the car drove all
the way home forgot right of course
naturally we knew that's what was going
yeah I do my shit's on zero so I'm like
okay this is I I I'll probably make it
to the gas station but I gotta make sure
next time you leave the house I leave
you have to down the hill I'll go
neutral like right so I'm like okay do
that we leave town I don't drive for 10
days I'm sick so so I get in the car and
I'm like oh [__] yeah bad feeling been
there is this is
this does it even matter that didn't
drive for 10 days did the gas you know
what I mean like maybe it it can't help
so I go to to the gym again right you
don't get gas no I I do but I have to go
to the gym oh okay yeah I'm like I got
to go to the gas my car stops driving
whoa dude that's never happened to me
wow happen to me two times two two times
yeah damn dude what a bad feeling that
must be I'm on I'm on a street a very bu
busy Street pull over to the middle of
the street it's like got you know the
suicide Lanes I guess you call it right
ah is that what you call it I know what
you're talking about you know what I'm
talking about yeah that's what they call
it anyway um I'm in the middle there's
one there's two things one this two this
way two this way I'm on the middle one
mhm uh and I got to put the hazards on
wow so I'm
like what do I do well you know what to
do I know what to do I got to go get gas
yes yeah but I'm like should I walk
there should I leave the car I don't
want the car to get hit like it's just
here it'll probably be okay but you
don't know if you're a triaa member you
call Alea haven't bring gas but yeah
sure okay I which I am but I was kind of
close enough to the gas station where
I'm just going to Uber there and then
Uber back clever clever I get the
Uber I take the thing I buy a canister
of gas I fill it up I get another Uber
back yeah try to make sure that you know
the Uber doesn't doesn't spill and I
don't want to [__] God yeah yeah yeah
I get back the guy's so nice the guy's
like oh is this your car you want me to
help I was like don't worry about it
he's like are you sure I can help I mean
that's racist that you're doing his
accent but yeah but that's what his
accent was kidding dude
um and so and so I said oh don't worry
about it I can do it he's like okay and
then I go to
leave I get there the guy does a U-turn
he goes here's some water like just the
nicest guy in the world yeah okay yeah I
go [__] you no I'm kidding so that's
where I was a dick so I I get the thing
I put the gas gas in the thing I kind of
figure out how to do it it's not really
working but then I finally figure out
how to do
it uh and I'm like in the meantime I'm
like people are like P hey man love you
you know what I mean really and I'm like
oh really people do that to me I I don't
need help if that happened to me it
would it would happen to anyway so I'm
like in my head I'm like what comedian
is going to see me cuz I know a comic is
is going to drive by right right right
okay I'm almost done honk Hong I look
it's a Tesla ma brani oh wow okay I'm
like of course the nicest guy in the
world right you okay I'm like I'm all
right buddy I was like oh you need to
ride somewhere no don't worry about
anyway I do it start the car I'm covered
in gas wow you know I you couldn't help
it it was [__] everywhere car sits
like [__] every I'm I'm getting I'm like
but you know what I can deal with this
yeah but this is as much as I can deal
with you're at your threshold I'm and
and I know that and I'm like thank God
nothing else [__] Up's going to happen
uh oh
because I've dealt with as much I can
deal with I'm on my way to the gas
station I've got enough in the tank to
get there I've got credit
cards I'm good yeah you're good yeah I'm
good yeah I go to the gas station
yeah credit card
out oh no even worse go to the guy
station see one of the pumps says see a
tant for this pump so I go hey well not
that one that one drive up to the next
one
okay yeah I'm ready yeah declined so
dainty the way you just did that yeah he
declined hey but no it's not but no it's
not I'm rich okay dude so I go huh try
again declined crazy maybe Wells Fargo
is doing something silly you got one
more than one credit card though yeah
yeah so I go to my credit card has
nothing to do with Wells Fargo right if
this is Wells Fargo fault guess what I'm
about to figure it out yeah yeah yeah
decline
okay you're moving your body so much
it's crazy right now H okay so I go I'm
pissed yeah go into the thing are you
you oh wait wait I forgot to say before
this mhm I stink like gas I go into the
gas station attend the guy I say hey man
can I use your bathroom this is before I
go to even get the gas oh wow he
says we can't what and I say we can't
you don't need
help yeah SOLO Mission dude yeah dude
yeah
uh can I just use your bathroom dude
please and he goes like this we don't
have one and I I know he's got one
obviously because it's for employees
only oh right and I go like this buddy
really and he was like yeah we can't so
then I go back out so already you're
already you're already pissed so as much
as I can deal with the guys not going to
let me do but you know what I am dude I
get the rules if the rules is you don't
let somebody even if he's been a TV star
even if he's a huge comedian you don't
let him I don't want special privileges
okay cool I get the rules I totally get
the rules I get the rules so go back I'm
surprised frankly that you don't get the
rules but you do okay I do I get the
rules I stink I stink like [__] with the
gasoline I'm like all right I'll figure
it out a different way I go when the
credit card didn't
work right but here's the problem with
that you got nobody to be mad at so what
happens so you get and I
say
hey can I
uh the thing doesn't work the guy says
this is where it
just it was it it was like the
levies yeah the dam broke too much
weight against it he says did you try a
credit card what else would you try oh
dude singing for it
dude and I
said yeah I tried the [__] credit
card like that okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
does it work or what right here 20 on
[__] five right yeah and I got 20 on
five I went in there stink like [__] I
walked into restaurant next to watch the
but I was addicted to that guy oh okay
and that's my threshold and that made me
think of that okay I mean that been such
a bigger dick to people for such less
than that in very recent memory yeah oh
really oh yeah yeah yeah not me yeah I I
I mean I very recently was a huge huge
huge dick to the [__] parking lot
attendant that we park in to come here
really yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean killed him you know
just [__] it was when you got here
and it the blood's still like
this yeah no I'm I and I always feel bad
about it I got a temper problem you know
that yeah I know but it's [__] weird
though like it's weird you at least had
like you could look back and think oh
well this is what happened and why I was
so pissed and that was all leading to
that your point which is a good one you
never know what people are going through
you that wasn't in isolation you yelling
at the gas station attendant which is
why I brought up if just that happened
and you were that big of a dick you'd be
a huge
[__] guy in duress who's had it up to
freaking fraking ass here huh you never
know people going through and not that
like you know literally saying that
about something you said though which is
not great you're saying oh yeah that's
so interesting you never know what
people going through you said I'm so
interest that's so interesting I brought
that up and I said that in such a way
but yeah it's true man nobody is just or
not nobody it's just very rare that a
dick is a dick for no like without any
leadup without any other context that is
necessary to consider like just a dick
for dick sake Corella DeVille type [__]
is rare just bad guy in a 9s action
movie yeah it's just rare dude I don't
like them for no reason I love those are
my favorite characters the guy the guy
the characters who don't like each other
for no reason is one of the funniest
tropes in Hollywood yeah you know what
I'm talking about yeah it's better when
a I mean it's a better when a bad guy is
understandable that's a better movie
it's so [__] funny to me when there's
a guy that's just
I I God I love that I love that so much
but can you think of one or what no cuz
there's so many you know what I'm saying
yeah they still do that kind of you know
yeah guys are just bad guys rotten
people yeah all right anyway we can do
another one
next what's up Chris what's up Matt uh
this is the guy who lied about the girl
who sneezed yes dud pause it small
update on that what happened this is the
guy one of the best actual submissions
ever I
think this guy didn't tell his new
girlfriend that he was traveling abroad
with his best friend who was a girl oh
dude this was great yeah and she called
him one night and they were sleeping in
the same room as friends like this guy
literally is not bangar ranging on this
girl at all and she while he was on the
phone with his new girlfriend sneezed
and it ruined and I think he's about to
give us an update so yeah it yeah and
and's girlfriend's like who's that why
have you not told me that you're on a
trip it turned into a big fight yeah
shouldn't have lied was dumb go ahead
yeah did not work out she ended up
getting back with her ex-husband who
actually cheated on her so wow weird way
things work but uh new question for you
um my mom or my grandma right will
always like do me a favor or tell me
they'll do something for me and they'll
kind of mess it up or they'll Jack it up
or not do it right and it's something I
could have done myself not really a big
deal it was nice to them to offer for me
you don't have to but it kind of created
more work now that it was done wrong or
I have to redo it or you know didn't set
aside time to do it because I thought it
was going to get done super easy but
then I'm the [__] cuz I'm pissed
about it right so uh what should I do in
those situations uh when somebody offers
to do a favor and then they do it wrong
or they Jack it up oh do I have any
right to be mad Jack it up I don't know
let me know thanks guys always says mess
it up or Jack it up like those are two
different things they mess it up Jack it
up or goof it up what who what I I get
it but what did he say about his mom or
grandma what did that mean what did he
say I like he saying that they do that
his mom and his grandma do this yeah
apparently I guess I just didn't hear
that yeah okay like like hey I'm I'm
going to build a shelf oh I'll build it
for you and they [__] it up right
Grandma's building him a shelf that's um
yeah I do you have a right to be mad at
them again if you're not specific it
just depends on the favor if you want
something done right do it yourself this
is basically and here's why very
straightforward reason nobody cares as
much as you unless it's a pay job and
the people care about their paycheck but
generally speaking nobody and it's not
even their fault nobody could care as
much as you you're you of course you
care more about the thing that you want
to happen in your life than anyone else
it's not their life as much as they
could care they could never fully take
on the amount of care that you have that
being said can you be mad at someone
it's context dependent what did they do
and how bad did they [__] up if somebody
says hey uh like if it's like this right
Chris I know you're busy let me pick up
Calvin from school to help you out that
day I know Christian's out of town well
whatever you got a ton of stuff to do if
she's out of town she's not cheating and
then and then I have and then I'm like
45 minutes late and I make Calvin wait
in like a place that might even be
potentially unsafe he has every right to
be absolutely furious with me but like
is it that kind of thing or is it like
oh wait you need to hang up a a a thing
on your wall in your house I I'll do it
for you when I do it a little bit
crooked like then you don't that's
unforgivable right like it just depends
it depends yeah it depends true that's
actually the only point you need to make
that's why I wanted him to be specific
it's like what is thing and I get it now
and you [__] up you [__] up he
[__] up dude he [__] you know what he
[__] up and then he [__] up the
sneezing thing he [__] let's not
forget about that you thought that was a
i i I remember we disagreed about that
you thought it was unforgivable that she
sneezed it is I I understand we don't
need to rehash it but I remember
thinking but a Snee it a Snee it's like
the
most God's will thing that there is you
can't not see you know it's coming dude
okay yeah but for how long sometimes
longer than put your face in the [__]
pillow dude you're in a hotel room but
she didn't he didn't explain properly
the necess he should have been like hey
you can't make a F sound it's his fault
he didn't the whole the whole the whole
thing is his fault see this is the thing
that I don't like about things that are
faults people's faults it's it's it's
his fault completely 100% but it's
secretly also her fault but see this is
exactly what we got an argum about I was
saying it's only his fault you were
saying of course it's mainly his fault
but in this instance the sneeze thing
was her fault I don't agree I think it's
all secretly you know I think it's all
get up to and God knows but he's like
but you're on thin ice you know right
it's unspoken we understand you messed
up we let you in here but that was a
hell sneeze
right hell sneeze dude wow uh all right
you got another one or no that could be
the episode title yeah it's a good one
what's up Matt and Chris love you both
love your show uh my question is about
my
allergy it is you know when you go into
an office and there's a sign and it's
like please don't wear your perfume cuz
people have allergies you're like that's
not real
no that's me no I agree and I work in an
office where people use way too much for
Breeze the bathroom breze sucks it
happens every day they use like 10
seconds of f Breeze and then the whole
office is like a f Breeze office and it
makes me like want to puke a headache
even more so gives me a migraine and I
don't know how to address that can you
tell someone not to use f breze in the
bathroom yeah I also sound like a wimp
being like perfumes make me sick so what
would you guys say dude first of all let
me just say I agree with you I [__]
hate perfume so much and I think it it
makes me sneeze I can't stand when Dude
I I could see someone I haven't seen in
a long time hug them and if it's a woman
and be like oh hey and dude I had a vest
that I liked that I like this I knew
this she was at the Laugh Factory this
woman she was like Hey I G been a long
time she hugged me I couldn't want that
[__] vest any
more dude could you wash it it was like
a weird material though dry clean it if
you I don't think it helped I think I
did and I don't think it help whoa what
it was horrible but not all perfume is
like that
but dude your came unplug oops when just
now you know it's amazing that that's
never happened to me and it happens to
you all the time it's really interesting
it's not my fault oh it's secretly
Anthony's fault okay keep going no it
sucks that uh I thought find
perfume offensive I find fabreeze
offensive I find listening to music in a
car offensive if you're with someone
you're basically saying hey I know how I
know the best way to hang out which one
the music thing and the smelling I know
what the best smell is I got it
everyone well that that is a good point
but I have a question for you're a
[__] [__] if you're like you're
basically the guy taking the guitar out
of the party that's what you do when
you're putting perfume on right I agree
actually but here's yes dude here's the
thing
though why can't people use the right
amount of perfume what is going on I'm
not sure there is the right amount but
yes you are right there are people that
it's crazy why can't you just do the
tiniest drop because it's enough it's so
crazy dude if people who use a lot how
do you not notice dude it's like you're
you're bombing every place you go crazy
you're an awful person you're like
you're like a [__] Bigfoot you're
like Bigfoot you walk around you weak
like [__] people feel like
thisis ah this is beauty this is great
dude what you're supposed to do is buy a
swing set set up the swing set put it in
your backyard hire someone to go outside
and [__] stand with a perfume bottle
you get swinging and when you get really
high you go at the top [__] FK
fulcrum the you go spray it they spray
it and then you swing into the perfume
that's it that's the right you get one
shot dude and then the guy goes home you
pay him and then you [__] go to work
anything more than one spray of perfume
anything more than buying a swing set
setting it up hiring a butler to spray
that one spr when you're at the absolute
top of the fulcrum dude and swing into
it love s you are putting you are
basically an Armenian you are putting
too much perfume on
period yeah here's if you want perfume
have enough money to get a swing set
too what are these people thinking when
they spray more than one spray though
what's going on more than one spray
that's what I'm saying though more than
one spray yeah yeah people do sprays
I've never dated someone who uses
perfume so I honestly can't even I have
and you know what I do I say this is a
something that needs to stop but I mean
to I'm controlling I mean to be
controlling
I can't be around the perfume yeah it's
like it gives me a all all that should
need to be said is it gives me a
headache and perfume does give people
but here and they stop because I lay the
hammer down right okay well well not
because I lay the hammer they because
they because they respect you because
they say oh I'd rather be fear than love
though right no not me I'm like here's
the thing though there's something worse
than perfume and it's called colog there
is no cologne you're saying cologne is
perfume for that's right for
congratulations if you you wear cologne
yeah you are now a woman wearing perfume
no now you're a man wearing perfume you
are a woman now congratulations isn't
that weird though that it is literally
the exact same thing it's the same thing
what does it smell more called different
things it's like if it's like if me and
a woman were on a date and we both ate a
steak and I called it different just
because something different just because
I'm a man and she's a woman I had fish
what I had fish but it's a steak I'm a
man no I head steak you had Yaba daad
duie lost your [__] absolute mind
snap right before you said yab actually
that is a steak isn't it no it's a
yababa doobie but it's the same thing
we're both eating the same thing well
I'm a woman I call it a Yaba daad doobie
I'm a woman yeah
you're I thought you were saying
something different um yeah dude I
don't I I don't I I have is weird smells
any smells honestly I'm confused now why
are they call different things Kristen
will put out a [__]
candle and it's like doesn't it smell
nice and it's like yeah in passing if
you just okay cool but don't light
it you light it I'm done what are you
going to do with the candle not light it
and just have it out it smells nice
actually yeah or don't even have it I
agree that some candles are overloaded
on scent but like a nice candle is is
never too strong like the expensive
candles are like very mild I disagree
well no but but
I didn't mean anything by
it uh should we do one more is there one
more yeah let's do
it hey guys watching show for a little
while mustach really enjoy it one thing
that I've noticed is you guys talk a lot
about movies yeah and I've noticed
something about myself recently where I
will watch a movie based on the reviews
uh so if I see things on social media
like a movie's really popular uh then
I'll check it out but if there is a
movie that I'm interested in I'll go
check out like rotten tomatoes or IMDb
or whatever and see what people are
saying about those movies and I won't
just watch a movie based on my own
interests or something this is already
curious if you guys do that or what you
think about that let me know it's a
great question you are the man dude it's
a great question you asked such a good
question this is all of these have
actually been pretty good questions even
the first guy who asked nothing and said
nothing first one was a horrible
question uh well there was no question
just saying thank you for way too long
we appreciate it though
um reviews in general now this hasn't
always been the case but it is true now
that almost I would say 98% of reviews
you find on the internet are literally
this some random man or woman who you've
never met never will meet and very well
could have nothing in common with at all
writing something that is the equivalent
of them saying I like this movie or I
don't like this movie now why that
should matter to some random movie goer
with totally different interest and
whatever interest unto themselves only
nothing to do with the person who wrote
it's it's it's mindboggling why someone
like this guy who obviously lives in
Alaska would would care what some movie
critic in Seattle or New York or La
thinks about [__]
saltburn if it looks interesting to you
see it if it doesn't who gives a [__]
[__] what someone at moviephone.com
thinks he welcome to movie phone
remember that [__] no what is that no
clue when You' call oh God I mean very
vaguely they welcome to movie phone they
would tell you the movie times yeah oh
no you go you go press nine for Mickey
blue eyes Mickey bluee you hit n dude
whenever there's an be like 740 an
opportunity bring up from yep byon times
you always say Mickey blue eyes and
that's very weird
and a robot couldn't I mean I could like
what's a better movie to pick like I
[__] aced it by thinking of Mickey
blue no it's good yeah you did good I
you know it's another good one Jumanji
um well that's a good one I recently
watched Jumanji let me tell you guys
something I know it's for kids obviously
adventure movies whatever it is the
shittiest thing the original one well
I'm sure this the reboot is even worse
but who would ever watch that the one
not even the Rock and his eight
gajillion fans none of them watched
Jumanji even though he's in it you know
no one saw Jumanji no one saw the actual
movie uh even though it
exists Kevin Hart Jack Kevin is
literally in everything is the rock not
in janji he is he is right he is oh I
don't know rock and Kevin Hart are in so
many things together um but yeah no one
saw the Remake but the it's so bad it's
it was like mindboggling bad yeah isn't
Ben Stiller in it no Robin Williams Oh
that's Night at the Museum right right
right right right which Robin Williams
is also in um oh right that's what I'm
thinking of uh so hold on okay Jumanji
Robin William is in Jumanji correct okay
and it's really bad terrible wow I got
to look at it um so I got watch utterly
utterly utterly terrible and so as
Kirsten Dunces in it as like a kid oh
yeah yeah um this is a great an a
question what do you think about what
the guy said um
I think you should only go see things
that pique your
interest right but that's not exactly
answering his question yeah it is no but
is that Peak your interest because other
people said no because you think looks
interesting the trailer looks
interesting the synopsis or yeah yeah
yeah I I I don't I mean you know what
you like better than do know what you
like but you don't know what you like
before it happens though so I do
understand his question is
like like there is some sort of reason
to oh oh man everyone's talking about
this movie it must be good different
different if if if if you hear a bunch
of people being like oh man this movie
of course of course like participating
culture if you feel like so inclined
participating culture but you don't you
don't say oh the new the new jamanji
reboots out I'm going to go to to
moviephone.com and see whatever that
critic think welcome to movie pH
Meanwhile by the way movie critics now
are just people with computers well
right I somebody with 300 followers on
Twitter it's it's crazy like if you go
to see who are like verified movie
critics on Rotten Tomatoes which is the
worst I mean there are bad Rotten
Tomatoes is the worst there are bad
aggregator sites and then there's Rotten
Tomatoes that is the most piece of [__]
wipe your ass when I see some [__] 100%
fresh I want to [__] saw my testicles
off here's the deal there's only there's
one best rated movie of all time on
Rotten Tomatoes do you know what it is
wait Deadpool no what Paddington 2
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
critics reviewed Paddington 2 and gave
it positive aosi there isn't one
negative review of Paddington 2 on
Rotten Tomatoes there were hundreds of
reviews of Paddington 2 on seen it it's
unbelievable oh dude no I mean like what
uh yeah I didn't know wrong right the
thing about Rotten Tomatoes is and I've
always said this is the people who rate
the movie the specific movie that
they're rating either love it or hate it
nobody is just hey got to go on my
Rotten Tomatoes account and rate all
these movies it's it's the the the it's
that Seven Rings or 10 Rings movie the
Marvel one the Asian one that everyone
thought was so amazing on Rotten
Tomatoes okay a pile right of heaping
tan liquidy dog [__] okay it's so it's
so bad it got 100% okay because all of
the Asians are like
finally Oh you mean the users oh okay I
thought you meant okay yeah we're talk
about different things but yeah and then
of course because of that and and it
came out during this no Asian hate a lot
of the good timing critics were like we
love it sure yeah but the user ones are
the worst ones well that's that's even
worse than movie critic cuz they're just
doing the same thing but they don't know
how to write or think so they're just
like I liked it I liked it I like but
here's the thing movie going experience
isn't always isn't always so binary you
don't either love or hate movies in fact
how often do you love or hate a movie
it's rare Sal's a great example of it I
was like I don't know the whole movie
and then I was like yeah okay I like the
ending and I think I liked it honestly
that's as good as any movie criticism
you will read today what my brother just
said about sturn yeah that is the depth
of of uh criticism that you go that you
get when you go to these popular movie
sites like I don't even know is movie
phone a thing anymore probably movie
phone.com whatever those kinds of things
you know maybe Ash there are some movie
critics that are still interesting but
it's really they're really hard to find
Slant Magazine is interesting but it's
it's dead movie criticism is dead movies
are almost dead it doesn't bro I saw
this review this is such hor guy the guy
always reviewed my special's bad and he
he there are comedy special review
things god wow I didn't even know that
well that is the dumbest I agree cuz
you're just saying is it funny or is it
not funny that's to you exactly that's
what I'm saying yes dude this guy was
reviewing Matt R special and it was like
trashing Matt R of course bro and you're
saying of course because that's not
because that's the thing to do right now
yeah no I don't think Matt's not funny
no I know but
um it's it's so and then you and then
some somebody just took a screenshot of
the guy's profile picture and like
replied to it uhuh and it's like of
course this guy doesn't like Matt re oh
he's a [__] bald fat loser and Matt
R's like the most handsome guy that just
[__] thinks he knows comedy and
writes I don't even know I honestly
don't I don't even know the is he just a
guy that review that you know he's a guy
he's you see him around Montreal and
[__] like the festival he always review
my [__] back he obviously doesn't like a
guy like me he obviously does he's a
short fat bald [__] loser well there
are I'm sure there are plenty of short
fatball losers who do like you though so
I don't know of course I love fatball
losers me too but this fa bat loser I
don't like right of course and because
of that I'll call him a fatball loser I
see I see I see you know but it's like
it's like dude it's it's
so it's so and I saw he didn't like Matt
R I was like oh here this [__] guy
goes again
dude and he Matt's the biggest comedian
yeah he's huge so it's like any critique
I you it it makes no sense to ask your
friends even at that but that's the your
best bet yeah yeah that's your best bet
or just see a thing dude there's no
better
feeling than not knowing anything no I
mean not I literally you took me to see
sexy beast when I was like 15 I think I
was when it came out and I literally
hadn't seen a trailer I didn't know a
single thing about it I didn't even know
who Jonathan Glazer was and I was like I
me knowing nothing about it seeing a
movie in the theater that's that good
was like one of the best movie going
experiences in my life you're welcome
and yeah thank you uh and yeah but
that's obviously hard you can't just go
to the movie theater and be like uh that
one Paddington 3 you know um you got to
know a little bit about something but
sometimes the less you know the better
that sounds interesting based on the
little bit I know about it see that not
Paddington 2 you know what I'm saying I
agree okay see both yeah Paddington 2
fantastic do double feature uh do
Paddington 2 second what do Paddington 2
second yeah uh all right cool that's it
we're done we're done leave a comment
for us we love you uh go watch my
special grower grower diet chris.com
I'll also be in Sacramento and uh
albuquer and Phoenix and Brea go to
chris.com
uh most important ly sign up oh yeah at
patreon.com you are missing the best
show there is available on patreon and
it's ours isn't that interesting uh all
right happy New Year I hope the new year
is going extremely well so far for all
of you and we love you bye yeah see
you
hello
hello hello please hello
hello hello